and Ed Arnold is with us now he's a
research fellow on European security at
the Royal United Services Institute he's
a former British Army and NATO officer
Ed thanks a lot for coming in again
let's look at the overall picture on the
ground at the moment what is it
well Ukrainian counter-offensive the
rate of Advance remains impressive
particularly in the South but also to
the eastern Ukraine is now achieved
their primary political objective which
was to show the West that they could use
the Western systems their weapon systems
that they've been provided to take back
territory they're now pressing ahead
more military objectives which is to
liberate as many uh towns and cities as
possible before the winter comes and the
contact line goes rather static but also
it's to push the front line forward so
that all of the areas in red which
Russia currently holds would be in range
of long-range rocket systems that the
ukrainians have been supplied so they
can degrade Russian ability to prepare
for operations next year starting in
March okay let's look at the South
because there are reports that the
Russian lines there have collapsed so
have they collapsed and what would that
mean for them if they have yeah so in
the South it Remains the Ukrainian main
effort and they have started to press
very much in the west and the North and
really the Russian front lines have
started to collapse and having to move
and push back south to try and save
their forces and you can see that
there's roughly eight
um towns and cities that have been
liberated just in the past 24 to 48
hours the issue with the the Russians
have is when militaries have to withdraw
under that type of pressure they need
good commanders to be able to Rally
which the Russians just do not have and
also the ground there's no natural
defensive barriers to sort of reset
their rare front lines as it were so
Ukraine are really trying to push the
issue is there's no good options for the
Russians they can either collapse back
to curse on sort of the the safety that
the city will provide But ultimately
they need to move to the east of the
river I mean it's 15 000 Russian forces
approximately that are on the western
side and it's going to be a real issue
in all options that they have really you
know it's likely that they'll be forced
into a Surrender by the Ukrainian forces
okay so that's in the South let's look
at the East now what is the situation
there linear East is not much better for
the Russians at the moment the
ukrainians are continuing with their
approach that has worked which is
essentially to push in the Northeast and
sever all of the ground lines of
communication from Russia to Russian
forces within the East once you sever
those lines the positions for the
Russians become untenable and now a key
highway Highway 66 which is between
civatory and cremina that is now within
Ukrainian artillery range roughly 30
kilometers so the ukrainians are now
able to Target Logistics which has been
an issue for the Russians in the past
and the Russian command and control is
not functioning in the Easter either you
have this odd situation where Wagner
mercenaries further to the South around
City are actually pressing on offensive
operations as the forces in the north on
the defensive are being pushed further
and further east so it shows that the
the entire command and control network
of the Russians in the east not
functioning okay interesting thank you
so much hopefully see you next hour